foreign
[Applause]
among all fighting games Tekken has
probably one of the best design bosses
we've seen throughout the years
[Music]
so we've pulled together a survey for
our four most memorable skill testing
Final Bosses in Tekken
the main criteria here was how iconic
the boss is and how it gave players a
satisfying experience beating them
all right
starting off with our list is the main
antagonist from Tekken 6 as is ale
the creator of the devil and by
extension the devil Gene that curses the
Mishima bloodline azazil is a massive
creature his moveset Bears some
resemblances to previous Tekken Boss
characters such as his stunt attack and
the ability to fire lasers except larger
foreign
at number three unknown
she is the main villain of the Tekken
Tag Games having made her debut as the
final boss in the first Tekken Tag and
returning for a Tekken Tag Tournament
too
in Tag 2 she has June's moveset and
unique boss style moves in place of the
wolf spirit is her ability to form large
slime constructions from the floor to
attack her opponents commonly using
spikes and occasional Fists
oh
number three is the final boss of Tekken
3 and the sub boss of Tekken Tag
Tournament 2 the god of fighting ancient
ogre
[Music]
first appeared in Tekken 3 as the main
boss and eventually transforms into a
fire breathing Beast as his second form
called true ogre
foreign
[Music]
ogre style is a combination of many
fighting styles taken from Those whom it
has defeated it absorbs The Souls of
powerful Fighters and thus seem to be
able to learn their techniques
[Music]
and at number one the father of hiashi
mishma and the founder of the Mishima
zaibatsu jimpashi
[Music]
large and muscular jimpachi is an
intimidating figure despite his age and
when chimpachi is under the possession
of the spirit his eyes glow yellow and a
large fanged mouth opens in his abdomen
his skin also changes color and a
mistiara surrounds his body which makes
him a very menacing boss
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
the music and the stage of this final
battle has made it the best among all
the Tekken games not to mention the
difficulty of beating them
if Tekken 8's boss can be as close to
this let me know it's gonna be good
[Music]
so do you agree with our list
that's gonna do it for this video make
sure to subscribe to oterna TV for more
Tech and content and we'll see you next
time
foreign
[Music]